from screen junkie studios in the Heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
movie fights now your host Andy signor
hello screen juggies this is truly a
special episode of movie fights we're
going to have a fight but bear with us
cuz we have some massive news we're
about to share guys I know I've been
teasing you for months about a secret
project we've been working on this logo
has been frustrating you and everyone's
what's going on well T today is time for
the big reveal guys I just need to thank
you our loyal audience we wouldn't be
here without you you because of you
we've built a brand here that you come
back to week after week to discuss all
the things you care about I'm so
grateful you've given us your time your
passion um and your trust and so uh when
we read your comments and letters
there's one you know you don't always
agree with everything we say here but
there's one thing we do here from pretty
much all of you is you want more so I'm
proud to say today we're about to
deliver on that and we've brought a
little bit of a clip that'll say it
better than I can so let's cue
it there's been an
Awakening something big is coming from
the minds that brought you the screen
junkie show movie fights and honest
trailers comes a new streaming service
so massive so awesome so amazing it will
change the way you see movies and
television
forever uh can someone hit the lights
[Music]
screen junkies plus a new network
created entirely for movie fans
featuring shows from the most epic
voices and movies and TV Nick Mundy and
Dan
ml Jeremy
Johns Chris
stuckman Roxy
strier Spencer
Gilbert Andre
Meadows how it should have ended Alicia
Malone and Andy signor plus awesome
bonus content for the screen juny shows
you know and love and the premiere of
the first ever screen junkies original
scripted
series interns of
field uh can we get an intern to fix
that please Scream Junkies Plus us
premiering November
17th we're going to need a bigger
internet wow wow wow wow wow wow
wow oh my
face oh
jeez I can't read my script it it's here
guys I'm going to Huff this wow I bet
you didn't see that coming you're all
like oh people are going to be on the
show no this is life changing biggest
news in our history we are presenting
screen junkies plus wow oh my goodness
and right now we want to say we want to
be upfront that all of the shows that
you know and love Honest Trailers movie
fights the screen junkies show those are
still going to be free right there on
YouTube they're not going anywhere
that's right pal good I want everyone to
know that we're not taking away what you
want we're giving you more screen
junkies plus is a new streaming service
featuring daily content new exclusive
content from all your favorite
personalities and it's launching Tuesday
November 7 on an awesome new app that's
going to be on IOS and Android as well
as a completely relaunched screen
junkies.co uh guys we're building not
just one show here we're building over a
dozen new shows with some of your
favorite people we said it how it should
have ended Chris Duckman Jeremy Johns
Andre Meadows Alicia Malone and some
more amazing people will be announcing
soon as well as all the fine folks here
that we're going to quickly just talk a
little bit about what we're doing uh so
I I got it I guess start with this man
right here Nick Mundy what is Monday
Night Raw guys it finally happened I
trick screen jues into giving me my own
talk show that's right the weirdos one
and joining me is my reluctant co-host
Dan Merl some incredible guests and they
even gave me my own house ban Spenny G
and the sometime ban that's right he may
only be playing the bass but he's
tugging at the strings of your heart
holding it down guys and guess what we
are live and we are interactive that's
right you'll be able to call in Skype in
and you'll be able to tell all the
horrible things you think about me to my
face and guess what I'll get to be able
to say it back so every Monday you're
going to have a case of the Mondays on
Monday
night yeah people wanted your own show
Nick and now you got it you guys will be
able to call every week live with him
and thank God Dan's there to help even
it out a little bit I'll be honest but
I'm excited to see you two and do this
it's amazing excited Spencer tell us
about does it hold up oh man well I'm a
little distracted by Nick's [__]
service right now but I'll I got Silly
String in my arm hair trying to out of
my water doesn't hold up as like a I'm
I'm Whimsical yeah you're very Whimsical
um it's like a movie book club for all
the favorite movies you loved as a kid
and we revisit them me and a guest and
we see if they're actually still any
good you know we did Happy Gilmore we're
doing Demolition Man Starship Troopers
all these awesome things and I'm uh you
guys are giving me the discussion points
you tweet at me we talk about it we
determine whether this movie holds up or
not totally interactive I like you said
it's a book club each week you're going
to announce the movie they can watch it
with you you're commenting and you're
really going to debate whether it holds
up there's so much more stuff Hal tell
us what you're doing oh we're gonna have
some super cool screen junkies extras
stuff that you can see like the entire
Rock wedding with Nick Mundy uh there's
going to be moments that were too hot
for screen junkies maybe a Nick Mundy
nip slip you never know what you're
going to find on the behind the scenes
full unedited uncut screen junkies
that's right screen shows not going
anywhere Honest Trailers not going
anywhere but there's so much extra stuff
that doesn't make that especially in
honest trailers and we're doing a show
cut honest trailer commentaries or each
week and all the archived over 100
episodes we're telling you dirt we found
later or jokes that didn't make it delet
a lot of cool behind the scenes process
of how we do that show and also starting
the week of the 17th movie fights will
forever be live every Thursday night and
you at home will be able to join us to
call and fight with us uh through Skype
and online the show through our new show
after the fight which we're going to
have ending every show where you can
fight and say that wasn't right or you
didn't do that right you didn't do the
that that that was wrong judge all of
it's going to happen on after the fight
Talking Dead Talking Dead for movie
fights uh and the show everyone's been
asking for shows from all of us actually
but there's one show everyone wanted the
most I think and that was TV fights
we're finally delivering it I have to
say we don't have time to watch all the
TV we want to watch and I wanted someone
who really knew TV someone who watches
every show every episode from from years
and years ago to now uh and we went we
did an exhaustive search to be perfectly
honest we met with a lot of people we
met with so many personalities and we
found the perfect host and I'm I'm so
happy that she's here on The Dan cam
it's Roxy strier I have time to watch
all the TV in the world so I don't know
what that says about me but I love it
and I'm so excited to hang with the guys
and I'm bringing all you guys on to my
show I hope you're okay with that I'm
also bringing on Josh muga Kathy Kelly
Matt liberman a bunch of people who are
TV experts just like me so I'm really
really excited I love movie fights and
I'm going to love TV fights even more
Roxy I've seen you judging we've been
testing it and I give you the full gavel
of approval you've been doing a
fantastic job I'm so excited you're
joining us and I'm so excited for you
guys to see it yeah there's another
collaboration I'm pretty excited about
yes how it should have ended tell as a
show uh on our Network it's called after
the credits uh it's like Avengers had
the schwarma scene so we're taking other
movies that never gotten after credits
bump and it's an animated series that uh
Dan and Tina are involved in and they're
uh we're taking these movies one scene
further than if they were sure we
partnered with them before in other
episodes but this will be a a new show
that every episode we team up on I'm I'm
really excited for and they're funny
we're we're animating them as we speak
as I make a mess and they're really
funny um Spencer did a good job on those
uh also there's so much more stuff
that's going to be announced soon in
fact one just locked last night I'm so
happy to announce uh the schmo's ended
their phase five they're coming here to
do their new show the new Sho no show
live in our studio in December the show
their show we're not taking their show
away guys it'll still be on YouTube but
they're GNA also be on our app and we're
exclusively building a new show with
them so I'm so excited to announce that
DMO are joining us as well guys this is
so many amazing people uh and so much
exciting stuff but there's one I'm
really I'm I'm probably most proud of
and excited about our first Fay uh and
descripted content and that's what this
sh this field logo is uh it's called
interns of field uh Spencer tell us a
little about what the show is dude we
made an original scripted series it's
Eight Episodes long it's got real actors
real cameras I'm Blown Away by how
awesome this came out we I mean we have
real actors here every day we have real
cameras but this we we put we invested a
lot a lot of more money in this show
it's it's really F premium at at its
finest funny there's effects there's
celebrities there's jokes to anyone that
calls us Marvel junkies watch this show
uh we we take this whole superhero World
down a couple pegs and it's so much
better than I could have imagined what
is it though give me the log line well
it's like uh you know Agents of Shield
uh had a spin-off and we're like wow
where could they can go more boring and
procedural than Agents of Shield and so
we took it a step further and this is
the in the summer interns at a superhero
agency you have to deal with all the
shitty grunt work that you have to go
through dayto day that are the actual
real world ramifications from running
around with superheroes uh and we have
superheroes in our show we have our own
new superheroes you're going to
introduce we have the revengers the
revengers are coming guys get ready
there's so much to reveal about the show
we literally just stopped shooting it or
wrapped it so we're promos are coming
more INF so I'm so excited to share that
uh and and Hal there's some other fun
stuff right oh yeah when you sign up for
this service you're going to have VIP
access you're going to get news first
and you are going to have access in the
coming months to live movie fights on
tour just like mle crew and Drake or
whoever we are going to be on tour doing
movie fights and the energy in like an
auditorium when we are doing live movie
fights it's off the charts so we have at
least eight dates planned all around the
country all around the country at
different cons and events we've done
this a few times now and I I'm so
grateful and Amazed by the fans that
come out and I there's so like come to
my city we're going to try and come to
as many cities as we can this next year
and we're so excited and members of sh
plus are going to get exclusive special
access while we do it so it's insane and
I remember at the last one a fan was was
movie fighting against the champ Dan
Merl and he had Dan murl backed into a
corner oh it was super intense Dan is
currently hiding training Dan to go to a
best friend's wedding but Dan is going
to be involved in all this he's watching
the movie My Best Friend's Wedding but
he will be back um yeah so look out for
those live movie fights so guys this is
a new service it's a streaming service
we're going to have a new app on mobile
IOS and Android as well as a relaunch
dcom but yes this service will cost
money I don't want to not tell people
that like it's going to cost money
there's we're investing in a lot of
people and a lot of stuff um it's going
to be five bucks a month um that's like
the cost of a fourth of a Blu-ray right
uh smokes uh two beers uh beef jerky I
mean nudie Max popcorn at the movies
yeah uh it's it's but honestly there's
going to be a ton of different plans I I
want you guys to learn more about it as
we go um we're it's it's important
though that we could let you try it
we're not we don't want to just make you
pay for something and you don't know
what it is so we are going to give you
screen junkies three free months a three
free month trial uh on uh if you go to
scenes.com to sign up you're going to
get three free months to try it out
because we want you to get in there and
figure out what it is and not be angry
with us because I think you're going to
fall in love with it happy birthday
right plus I'm so excited because we're
actually going to offer some special
founders packs and this is going to have
exclusive screenies gear including the
first time ever the movie fight home
game guys oh yeah that's right this game
is fun this game is fun Dan mer is going
to come to your house thank the game
will and you'll be able to play with
your friends at home finally officially
that's right you'll be able to fight
with your friends and family and create
schisms that will last forever none of
us are friends anymore
so now I want to get the show going I'm
sitting in the wrong seat because how is
going to be the actual judge and I'm
going to fight today oh heck yeah Andy
wanted to fight it is my first time as
the judge of movie fights before you get
there how I just I want to wrap us up
one last thing I just I have to thank
you guys at home we couldn't we could
not be here without you this service is
actually I I promise all for you we want
to know what you want to see who should
we be partnering with how do we get you
interacting with us more often that's
the goal of this service is to really
give you more as you asked for and we
want to deliver it so please I hope you
love what are so excited to tell you
more in fact we're going to be sharing
Clips infos on the shows in the coming
days so if you aren't following us on
Twitter and uh uh Facebook screen
junkies please go do that right now and
in fact I'm going to be live tweeting
throughout this episode uh I think yep
hash screenjunkies plus if you want to
tweet me at Andy signore I'll answer as
many questions you can also I'm sure
tweet to screen junkies we'll get you
there too um as many questions as we can
answer so you guys can get more
information about this and hopefully get
excited with us um so I think that
covers it all how awesome I am so super
mega pumped all right and mark your
calendars right November 17 uh it'll be
available and we'll need your help and
we have so much more that launch week
it's going be have so much fun content
so get ready all right everybody let's
get down to business gentlemen lady we
got movie fights to attend to oh crap
God I had to prep all that too bad that
the time is the time is nigh okay we
have a lot of great fights today
including who should play Shazam to go
head-to-head with Mundy's best friend
The Rock what is the worst action movie
sequel of all time and uh if the Hunger
Games was a theme park ride what would
it be like all this and more and
remember you can pick pick your fight if
you don't like one of the topics we're
talking about then uh click the bottom
right hand corner and pick your fight
okay let's uh without further Ado
introduce today's
Gladiators he is the headwriter of
honest trailers you know him you love
him he's Spencer Gilbert and the host of
does it hold up oh yeah official now we
can finally talk about it what's up dude
good to be here oh awesome to have you
he's a formidable foe he's the host of
the new show show Monday Night Raw he's
a husband a writer an actor and a
screamer in bed Nick Mundy all true in
bed uh guys this is going to be a party
let's let's get weird hell yes and he is
the co-creator of honest trailers the
judge jury and executioner of movie
fights today he's a player Andy signor I
hope I can get the fans to not hate me
as much as they hated me last time I F
loser idiot dumbass stup I get
passionate guys right off the bat just
like on the game I I take this show
seriously unlike some
people aunk Civil War shots fired
brother against brother I'm kidding they
don't think I'm kidding Nick's the best
beard on beard crime okay I will kiss
you so hard and oh that would the bear
Community would love that jul
Julian and uh now Dan murl is out of
town this week so uh the Dan cam is now
the Roxy cam the fact Checker today Roxy
strier like the sound of that and the
host of TV fights I'm taking a page out
of Spencer's book that's my new show
heck I'm so excited people to see her TV
fights so fun right I mean you get to
judge though not easy right oh it's I
feel a lot of respect for you at this
point I didn't even wasn't fishing but
yeah just good luck and how best of luck
to you man cuz this a tough job thank
you how many hours of TV do you watch a
week like at least like three four yeah
you know three four 50 60 yeah it's my
life so there's a whole world out there
Roxy I'm concerned about don't care
about it don't care all right gentlemen
uh we're keeping score based on facts
passion and creativity and I'm going to
be looking for iconic answers that are
delivered at the height of your
powers I forgot I have to do some of
that this episode oh that's some of the
things you do
yes without further Ado play the Montage
now let's do this this is where we
fight fight fight fight
fight there it is Ken monab has set it
off just like Queen Latifa in the movie
Set It
Off are we bringing down the house we
are bringing down the house and it's
going to be uh Love and
Basketball
conclusion fact checking Not in Love and
Basketball thank you on the job this
show is as good as the Queen Latifa show
folks round okay let's do this round one
Taxi Mundy's best friend the be okay uh
that's a strike against you that's
another strike against you that episode
of Martin I didn't know order
order okay thank you uh Nick Mundy's
best friend the rock is still set to
play Black Adam in Shazam so Becca
Hansen gimme becky1 I like
that give me that becky1 asked us uh
using the hashtag movie fights who
should play Shazam and go head-to-head
with the rock I'll take this one first
uh Spencer all right well that's rude we
all know the rock is a force of nature
yes he's Beyonce for boys he's boance um
so you need someone that can match his
Charisma that can at least try to match
his sheer physical presence I'm going
with my boy chanam taters Channing Tatum
he is my pick for Shazam he's huge he's
funny he doesn't yet have a superhero
franchise I will believe Gambit when I
see it Gambit it's losing directors and
writers uh they're jumping off that like
the Titanic so I'll believe it when I
see it I want Channing Tatum to take on
the role of Billy Batson because Shazam
is a boy with the powers of Superman
Chang tat if you've seen Magic Mike or
uh 21 Jump Street he's got this
childlike buoyancy that you can see
underneath all the muscles so that's why
I think that he's the perfect pick for a
boy trapped in a superhero's body all
right Nick Mundy look I love chaining
taters just as much as the next fellow
whose question is sexual while watching
magic mik uh but I think we needed to go
something different let me just list up
a few names Hugh Jackman Natalie porman
Kristoff Watts javar baram all great
actors who were unknowns before their
big breaks that's why I want an unknown
to play Shazam the rock is this
charismatic wonderful person who is a
great person and friend and great at
marrying people and we need him to pick
the person and shape and mold him in his
own form to play B Billy Batson we need
someone who's not been corrupted by
other words and ears and other directors
we need someone to play Billy Batson is
pure just like Shazam and we need
someone pure and unknown that we can
come and enter This World of Magic uh
through his eyes and that's why we need
an unknown to play because honestly
there is no one out there who can
compete honestly and it probably should
just be the rocking glasses that who
should play him but you guys wouldn't
let me choose that answer so it should
be in aote okay coming off of what Nick
just said he's right no one can compete
that's my problem with this you put rock
is the villain who can you put up to
believe can actually take out the rock
so I'm going with the only guy who's one
of the guys who's only actually taken
out the Rock and that's John Cena whoa
I'm taking John Cena because one I don't
actually take this movie as seriously as
everyone else I think this movie is kind
of silly I already we already have
Superman we already have Man of Steel I
don't really care about Shazam I only
care because the Rock's now in the
villain and it's interesting but like
anybody you put up against him is just
not GNA I don't care you picked a boy he
is a boy and that's the exact problem
when he turns into Shazam you need a man
and he's not a man you didn't even pick
anybody you're just said unknown that's
such a copout answer it is not a cop out
then give
me the best wrestler to beat the Rock
You could have picked Brock Lesnar you
could have picked Stone Cold Steve
Austin you could have picked the
Undertaker no you picked John Cena the
worst out of those guys The Rock kicked
his ass and and let me just let me just
bring up some quotes that John Cena has
said about the rock all right we're
mixing it up now we're mix it up there
is a part where this is John Cena said
before the Wrestlemania match there's a
part where I'm supposed to say I look
forward to WrestleMania because I
personally respect the rock I don't John
Cena and then and then he said I'm
already bored finally The Rock has come
and he's never going to leave again and
then he left again CH John Cena on the
rock look at this history I love this
this they hate each other that's perfect
it's a villain and a hero why why would
John Cena make a good Shazam well I
think because he's a well I don't like
the character Shazam I'm putting it out
there to be sorry but I just I don't
he's a kid and he becomes Shazam and
he's the the hero I think John Cena I
I'll agree John Cena's not the best
actor but I think he can play the man
the guy who shows up after the kid and I
think it's going to be fun to watch him
C I'm going to root for the rock no
matter what so I might as well have
someone I want to see him beat up the
character Shazam is not the man he's a
boy in a man's body and John like us
yeah like us John Cena John Cena's
Persona is like this aggro white rapper
like Oh I'm a tough guy like that's not
Shazam Shazam is like the kid is doing
the acting thank you the the Cena is
just the body that the
going to channel a teenage boy and John
Cena is I'm sure he was never a teenage
boy how like well little sure he has no
experience being if you watch John Cena
the character he's like he's Eminem he's
like this tough guy that 8-year-old's
love but he doesn't act like and Chan
Tatum is more or less that he's better
John Cena but he's still John Cena but
it's not like well you've given up
you've just straight up yeah Spencer
tell me why an unknown wouldn't work
it's not fair I mean sure if if the Rock
picks the next was it not fair when Hugh
Jackman showed up as Wolverine who could
have predicted that well there's Hugh
Jackman and then there's you Portman you
pick the I'd like to fact Hugh Jackman
and Portman made movies before but they
never had anything like impactful okay
yeah you're going to pick someone who
has a sad card right now they're not
going to grab someone like you didn't
even pick one that you're betting on
because I don't know who he is I'm not
I'm you thrown up you don't know who he
is thank you why is Channing Tatum a
better choice than John Cena well
because Channing Tatum like I said he
has that boyish energ about him he he
channels uh his inner child it's shining
through no matter what role he's playing
whereas John Cena is a kid trying to act
like a like an old tough dude like he's
kind of half jug he's kind of this like
he's wearing Jorts he's rapping everyone
hates him I everyone above a certain age
hates John Cena so I've actually met
John Cena he a good guy he's a really
good guy he did the Fred movie which I
worked on and was in it but my point
being is Rock playing The Rock no it's
called acting and they're doing acting
hold on just because John Cena plays
that annoying doesn't mean he's not a
likable boyish guy who can pull it off
and I just don't buy chenning Tatum
against it I think Chan Tatum's too good
for this it's too fun Chan tum was they
killed off the rock killed them off
already in GI Joe like to me it's like I
don't want to rematch baby well he also
killed John Cena in many many wrestling
matches here's the thing here's the
thing I've never played this card before
I'm playing it I've asked the rock hey
who's going to play Shazam he said
probably an unknown
unknown great when did you ask him
for this humble but I just feel like
both of you have thrown in the towel
like no one can compete with the rock
chain Tatum has a shot to at least CH
Tatum is 4 feet S no he's he's like six
feet tall can you can you fact check
that Roxy CH Tat's height Channing
Tatum's height but the thing is is like
he's the protagonist of the movie you
can't give up on the protagonist it's
called Shazam it's called Shazam not
Black Adam so the rock is going to be
great you know he's going to steal his
scenes but the rest of the time you're
stuck with Billy Batson we all think the
rock is great I want the rock to pick
and choose and mold someone who he
thinks should play Billy Batson because
he is the best person ever okay let's go
to final thoughts all right uh Spencer
give us your uh final take on the
situation you just don't want to
sleepwalk through the movie just to get
to the villain scenes you want someone
that's at least entertaining and that
fits the character which is kind of an
adolescent boy trapped in a big guy's
body and that to me is Channing Tatum
Nick I don't think there's anyone who
can play Billy Batson yet I'm sure they
exist in the world and I think the is
the person to find him since he's
producing the movie and more less
running the show so I CH I trust in the
Rock choosing who should play Billy
Batson and John Cena is the worst person
you could have chose to play it I would
watch if you pick Stone Cold Steve
Austin I would watch the [__] out of
that I disagree he's sells the most
merchandise out of everybody I've looked
it up he does he's the
most he's one of the most he's more he's
he's very popular is all I'm trying to
point out whether you hate him or you
love to hate him or you he's a popular
figure so I think that's unfair and I
think it's more fun to watch them in a
big superhero movie and I think it's
unfair to say he can't play character
because The Rock has learned how to do
that very well and he he's gotten better
over the years scorpion king is not an
acting piece when you go watch it he's
gotten better and I think Cena is
playing a good character and he's acting
as that character and I think I get
confusing you're saying he's the boy but
I think Chan's too good for it in a way
of like so the kid I agree he's too good
the kid the kid is the port and I think
John Cena is the perfect way for the kid
to grow up into that into that that kids
love John Cena like especially little
kids it's even more exciting for them to
do it right just I don't buy magic mic
doing that I don't I don't why get why
you guys hate this fo quiet Fox Okay uh
wow uh let me borrow from Andy this is
tough okay this really is uh this I mean
uh I I have one this is the time the
tries men Souls trying to decide between
this Nick I'm going to I'm going to take
you out already it does feel like a cop
out you're all silly does feel like a
little bit of a cop out and I think your
love from the rock kind of overwhelmed
you cuz it's like oh no one's good
enough to go against The Rock yet uh
Roxy you have some facts some facts for
you Tatum is
61 close enough yeah he's big John Cena
beat the Rock WrestleMania in 2013 he
did so that did happen he lost in 2012
also Tatum is confirmed for Gambit so
far so that that happened um and I just
want to let you guys know oh look and I
just want to let you guys know that
Queen Latifa was in just right with
common which was a basketball movie and
he a basketball star so I see what
happened there I appreciate that which
was important to this round it was very
important M uh it comes down to John
Cena and Channing Tatum who uh are very
they are similar physicality when you
when you look at them they're both like
white guys with Buzz
Cuts they and um Andy you had it but you
said one thing you said one thing that I
feel kind of you pulled the rug out from
under yourself when you said uh that
John Cena's not the best
actor he is at the end he's playing that
character is the fact that he's a good
actor you did say he's not the best
actor and I I feel like better Thana I
feel like CH Tatum would be the one
person who could bring the fun and go
toe-to-toe with The Rock in this guess
I'm the only one that wanted a good act
going with Spencer Channing Tatum One
spencer take I guess I'm the only one
that wanted a good actor in a movie that
I'm looking forward to J war is Jorts
too it's a I know you guys are all
clowns round two
children the first teaser for World of
Warcraft movie just went up the first
teaser trailer for The World of Warcraft
movie simply called Warcraft dropped
this week so Rick at crazy Celtic Rick
asked us what video game franchise could
legitimize video game
movies and we are going to start with
Andy this time oh okay
uh so I think it's uh video game movies
aren't working just because it's a
different it's just it's weird and I
think uh the only one that can you need
to pick something super iconic and I
think more classic to to do what the
question said oh damn it uh which is
what could legitimize them right and I
just feel like you have to go back to
well so I'm going with uh Legend of
Zelda I think there's so much to M there
I think we've never had like a good
never-ending story type of movie since
then and I think that's a type of movie
that you could turn into a family
adventure in a way with enough
characters in background and and and
storytelling and Adventure that could
actually pull it with the right director
and script clearly um but I think uh
Legend of Zelda has so much to mind that
I think it would if you did that you're
like oh okay the the the worthy ones the
big franchise video games can be turned
into something well and I that's my pick
Zelda all right let's go back around to
Spencer I'm going with Bioshock um this
is the first game I ever played that
felt like a work of art as I was playing
it more than just entertainment this is
a game that's in the Smithsonian when
they did a video games As Art Exhibit um
for those of you that don't know a quick
recap you're in this abandoned 1940s
style Art Deco crumbling underwater city
that so you're picking the first one the
first one just the first one and uh it
was this place built to be free from
government control but something went
wrong and it's full of these crazy
junkies and you unravel this mystery As
you move through it this is a game that
is bad for video games but great for
movies it's linear it has a story with a
beginning a middle and end a cool plot
twist cool characters that's annoying
for a game but perfect for movies it's
like the big budget guo Del Toro film
like there's so much detail and there's
so much atmosphere you're in these
crumbling skyscrapers there's fish
outside the windows it's Unique and more
than any video game which is weird it
has something to say about life and the
government and freedom of Will and stuff
like that you NE it came out of nowhere
you do not expect to get this from a
first-person shooter so that's why I'm
picking Bioshock okay Nick lay it on us
I don't really play video games I don't
have a problem with them I just don't
it's not a thing I do I play every other
Madden and then I play Halo because I
played in college and it's the one game
I get every three or four years because
I enjoy playing Halo and I think there
are a lot of guys a lot of people in the
world that play Halo they I I know a
bunch of them and like we still hang out
from college and play and it's the one
game that kind of like transcends just
beyond video Gamers I know it might not
be the best game or blah blah blah I
don't give a damn um pretty good game no
it's great I enjoy it I I'm playing it
tonight all these are good games yeah um
but the cool thing about Halo since the
beginning and now it's on the fifth or
6th one it's got this great epic Space
Opera that I like for especially for one
reason is that it's one man against I
mean there's other people but it's one
dude against this entire like Space Ace
race uh Zombie thing and it's badass
it's playing Halo is some of the better
movies I've seen in the last 10 15 years
it's enjoyable it's great I it just
needs to bring people together all
strong answers I want to go back around
in order and I want you to kind of lay
out what your movie would be what's the
basic plot of your movie okay Andy uh
sure and but I also want to take them
down but I mean I I don't have a full
pitch on it ready but I again I'm going
back to never inning story which I feel
like had sort of a dark Whimsy but still
for kids um and I think that's the type
of thing you can do because it is kind
of a kids game in a way and it gets
darker in certain SP Hobbit um but it's
I don't want to go The Hobbit because
that that's exactly my problem I Never
Ending Story just worked better for me
in a darker funner way and I think Zelda
has similar challenges of you know the
statues and things where you had to like
to me that type of movie on a grand on a
grand scale of today's standards with
the right director and script and the
characters you know and love I just
think would create a really fun thing
that then people are like oh there's
there's so much story to be told through
the games just yes it's a princess and
you're saving it you can reevaluate you
could make the you could make Zelda more
more prominent maybe she's not rescuing
maybe she's part of the action there are
ways to take that I think enough in
there whereas I worry these two they're
more shoot them up and I can go more on
that but I'll I'll got I like that you
gave me a feel of like the texture and
what the movie would be like give me a
little bit just not about the game about
your movie yeah well the the nice thing
about Bioshock is it already has a great
story this is about a character who's
washed up in this amazing uh underwater
environment where he doesn't know what's
going on and it is a mystery that's
slowly revealed to him and he's
basically this Pond between uh these
people who are vying for control trying
to rebuild this city one of them
represents uh uh the idealist and what
uh of freedom from uh government control
and religious control he's kind of a
standin for citizen C and and an Rand
and the other is kind of this mobster
that recogn that represents the uh the
Dark Side of of people having complete
freedom and uh you don't know which one
you're working for until about 80% of
the way through so this is a a a movie
with big ideas and it already has a plot
you just talk 80% of the people out of
of this country out of watching that
movie with all that gobbly guie just
here's what Halo is when you break it
down it is Death Wish meets star warss
it's one guy versus the Empire it's
Charles Bronson killing the [__] out of
people and and it's it's fun and awesome
and epic and it's an opera and I just
want to see like like give him $200
million I care more about seeing this
than like any DC or Marvel movie I'm
more excited about playing Halo a guy
who doesn't play any Halo like play any
video games you'd rather see a Halo
movie than any DC verse Marvel oh oh no
DC and Marvel movie not DC or Marvel
yeah definitely here's my problem or
sorry you done and then by the way
nevering story wasn't that great never
story was terrible and I don't want to
see we'll find out on does it hold up I
don't want to see I don't want to see
like another like nine-year-old in like
a nymph costume you know like I'll watch
hook like Hook is a better version of
your game all right none of us here want
to see a 9-year-old in a nymph costume
that's the well I was going to say I
think all three of these are have have
the potential right but I think yours
has too much story I think yours is
better as a series there's so much to do
in yours and in fact I looked it up the
developers the directors who've made the
game they've all admitted you can't make
a good movie it's too there's too much
to tell and yours would be a better
Netflix or HBO series to me and that
that me can't legitimize video game
movies is where I'm stuck and I'm I'm
I'm using for my argument and with
Bioshock same problem it has to go both
of these are more mature which I think
also is a problem of legitimizing them I
don't believe it'll be successful if you
do go dark and R which is the problem
Bioshock had when rinsky tried to make
that movie and wanted to go hard R and
and get the blood and all the stuff that
the game is about and they got cold feet
Watchman didn't do well and they didn't
want to do it so again I think all of
these are right but the way I I I feel
like I can fight these two is that point
alone I don't think they'll get the
Justice they deserve because it's too
expensive to make it properly and I
think Halo you could probably justify
but I don't think you could do it in one
movie I points in there Zelda's been
around for 30 years if they were going
to make a good movie about it they would
have done it well nintend
Super Mario Brothers and they have too
much IP that they should be doing and I
think that's the first one you could
take out and actually do it and I think
that's what we want we want Nintendo
movies Metroid Spencer Spencer can you
take down either one of these beardies I
with pleasure I take a issue with the
fact that Halo you think Halo has too
much Story I mean you're a guy that's
what they say okay I mean I know that
there's expanded universe there's novels
and stuff why they work at video games
and not movies CU they're dumb the game
is you shoot aliens um and to me my
problem with Halo is it's
I mean we're on Halo 5 by now I know
they threw in a couple new things to
shoot but you're walking into corridors
you're shooting them and you're moving
on to the next level I mean I don't see
the story there I don't think that's
legitimizing it it can I tag team on you
cuz I agree the only the one that did
that before was called doom and they
couldn't even do it with the rock
oh but you're talking about a guy how
many times has he link had a rescue how
many times has link had a rescue Zelda
and here's the problem with Bioshock
I've I and probably a [__] ton of people
have never never heard of it like so if
they make a movie unless it's the best
movie ever made I don't think a ton of
people would go to it Halo has the brand
recognition that would could enough
people would go to it make enough money
and then legitimize this is talking
about legitimizing yeah the question is
and what's the biggest Blockbuster the
question is what would be the coolest
new like action what would legitimize it
what would legitimize a movie franchise
is what would make the most money no
agree I think the same page legitimizes
critically because the one thing that
video games
never done they've never been good
movies that's what will legitimize them
if if if we were talking about
critically we'd be on raid n right now
and they wouldn't have shut down the
American version of The Raid we're talk
about legitimizing the biggest movie
brand would make the biggest movie and
if they do it half decent and then
follow just the story too much story of
Halo they just follow that that's a
better movie than most things that are
coming out I agree and as I said in the
beginning that's why they won't do it
because they have to invest so much
money to make that right and I think
it's too dangerous and I don't think
that movie will succeed
I also think it's to it's Resident Evil
in a way and I think that's final
arguments uh let's start with Andy I
just think his is is will end up
becoming a resident another Resident
Evil movie which we've seen to many too
many times yes it could look better but
that's going to mean it's more expensive
and I don't think it'll do as well as
those movies do and then that won't
legitimize because they'll have spent
too much on like an artistic director
that'll make then movies fall apart and
then I said it with yours I just I they
the filmmakers the the developers and
the director of the games didn't think
you could pull it off Peter Jackson
couldn't pull it off all back down I
think there's no one really knocked
Zelda down for the record he doesn't
want to see NS whatever he didn't they
didn't final closing and I think that
that says it because we all love that
story and there's enough to pull there
with the right script and director to
make something really fun okay uh
Spencer well Zelda to me has a
protagonist problem link never speaks
outside of grunts so there's nothing to
build on there as far as your hero but
I'll just say the way I interpreted the
the question was legitimacy to me means
artistic legitimacy this means a movie
that people are going to say oh video
game movies can work as pieces of art
not video game movies can make money and
to that effect Bioshock like I said in
the Smithsonian one of the highest re
reviewed games of all time deserves its
place people could say oh wow maybe
there is more to video games than just
shooting people with a gun or I don't
know what link does ah like or whatever
collecting pieces of the Triforce this H
there's something there's Big Ideas
going on in BioShock that would
legitimize it all right and Nick Mundy
yeah um I'm getting already a great
version of Link uh with Arya Stark in
Game of Thrones it's not going to be
better than that it could no it's not
cuz Arya Stark is stabbing people to and
no Arya Stark is better we don't need
link her is link aw you tried pitching
me you tried he's not in his head we're
getting it we're already getting it
she's already link they're not in their
heads too she's already Link Link never
slid anyone's throat from behind like I
know which is way better and then you're
trying to pitch me bios I still don't
know what this game is besides like you
know a philosophy term paper um the
biggest movie The biggest video game
franchise would legitimize the uh video
game genre as it were and that's Halo
and I'm getting a
beer all right what a colossal
confrontation colossal waste of time
okay so Spencer you were winning me over
big time you painted such a cool picture
of what Bioshock could be but then you
brought in Ein Rand and Citizen Cane and
I I feel like I feel like that is like
you're you're getting too thinky and
like too intellectual when I feel like
video games need they capture our
imaginations and take us on this journey
and it's just getting a little too down
the rabbit hole with intellectualism so
it came down to Nick and Andy and Nick
you had the best line of this I love
Death Wish meets Star Wars uh that's
amazing but I feel like you idiot Andy
hit these points as far as as uh the
creators said it should be a series and
I feel like Andy took down both of you
enough and painted the picture of a
Whimsical Journey that could really be a
p a movie that captures our imaginations
and I feel like that's what could lift
video game movies because we've seen the
shoot them up we've seen the Kill Them
All video game movies uh what Andy uh
sort of envisioned was the best one to
me that could re-energize and Andy gets
the point yes I'm not going to get a
zero it's all want to do
today I don't think I've got a point in
a thing
and don't blame me this time I
don't
fellas round three you didn't even ask
Roxy how come on oh Roxy and did I what
did we miss what we miss couple
important things to say it's my it was
my first it's my first time hosting Ro
there's a little more variation in link
sounds um it's
ha G the and ah so there's
very check fine there
you know if that's all link says maybe
John Cena can play link because they're
both they both deserve each other I want
to let you guys know Never Ending Story
has an 81 on Rotten Tomato so that's
pretty good and Nick Mundy tweeted on
June 15th 2015 video games are dumb
since they stop making final fight oh
yeah Hagar wow wow deep deep searches
you went into the Twitter it's the Roxy
cam today careful Dan hell yeah okay I
also said a lot of other things a lot of
other things don't go down that whole
too deep don't start repeating Nick's
political
tweets okay um round three it was
announced it was announced this uh past
week that Sandra bulock is headlining an
all female version of Oceans
11 pitch an all female version of an
existing movie or franchise and we're
going to start with Mr Nick Mundy yes
okay guys imagine this imagine a Lord of
the Rings movie that's only an hour and
45 minutes long imagine a Lord of the
Rings that doesn't have stupid walking
trees Eagles and Bor air lifs imagine a
fellowship that doesn't Splinter apart
at the first time of trouble and then
that image my friends is an all female
cast of Lord of the Rings the age of man
almost ruined Middle Earth now it's Tam
for the age of woman with Aragon with em
as Emily Blunt I made this really
quickly uh you got Hermione as Frodo you
got Lena Dunham as Sam you got chori
Weaver as Gandalf the Rocks up there the
rock is Arwin the rock is rwin you got
uh I see what you did there cuz she was
a girl yeah you got Michelle Rodriguez's
uh Bor Mir you got yeah Pippen yeah it's
a it's a really good cast you got
Kirsten wig as Gollum uh Tilda Swinton
as sarmon yeah no this is uh I like how
Christan wig is wearing a bald cap there
yeah no here's theeth Banks is gimly wow
yeah no this is a Rihanna is legol lost
this is a good cast here's the thing
Lord of the Rings Guided by The
Fellowship of woman would get to Mordor
in a d and a half tops they don't they
would work together they would get along
everything would be great and women are
awesome and I like also my wife picked
all this because I trust her and I
didn't have time and she picked this
list make fun of the list now you've
made it clear we're making fun of doar
well your wife is delightful but I am
holding you accountable for everything
here okay how great would this be um
potentially maybe okay Andy talk to us
uh so I want to see something fun I want
to see something different I don't
necessarily have a perfect cast for it
but here's what I want to see I want to
see jackass with girls I want to see
Jill ass that's right guys get it but no
for real bridesmaids proved girls can be
dirty girls can have fun girls can be
funny and I think if you could get I
don't know if you could get these people
I'm being honest but you might have to
find some unknowns so playing that card
but I did at least put some names here
if you got like a Sarah Silverman or
Nami Schumer or Natasha lar Angela
trimber uh even like a round Rousey to
like go and just f with people and
because they're girls and they could get
away with a different way like you could
go gross you could do like menstruation
stuff you could do poop stuff like they
did I think you'd truly surprise people
because what's fun about jackass what's
fun about jackass is they are idiots and
you love it and you laugh at it but you
sort of you expect them to do what
they're doing because that's what they
do but to see a tag tag crew of women
doing that to F with
people pun joke geez sure it can be
whatever but I just think that'd be so
fun to watch and just really fun movie
they were girl jackass members I know a
lot of us have watched jackass and say
where's the menstrual humor no but there
were also girl
jack we'll get to it very interesting
Andy uh Spencer L on us so I picked
Reservoir Dogs um I think that there's
this problem of like when they uh give a
a part a male part to a woman they just
make her like the strong female badass
Trope and uh and that's just as bad to
me as the damsin distress thing so I
want to have a group of girls who are
cool who are cool and potentially
violent and that to me is Reservoir Dogs
you know girls are they're allowed to be
tough they're allowed to be sexy but
they don't get to be stylish uh in a way
that's not objectif me girls yeah all
right they're high schoolers but I
picked um the franchise and one of the
only people that's writing cool uh
intense parts for women which is
Tarantino um you know all the girls from
Death Proof Alabama from True Romance
Jackie Brown these are all these amazing
female characters so we know he can get
the voice without resorting to uh you
know having them take their shirts off
and Reservoir Dogs is it's just like you
get his usual gang uh going you get
Juliet Lewis Patricia Arquette Rosario
Dawson Rose McGowen Daryl Hannah Uma
Thurman Lucy Lou um you know Reservoir
Dogs you don't lose anything by by
making them women they're they're not
physically tough but they're witty
they're raw they're cool there's no
reason why you couldn't make this movie
with women very I'll tell you why
because Quin Tarantino writes fantastic
female characters
the bride hello and I don't want to see
them go back into these men roles and
and you said it even so they cool and
violent that movie is is a great movie
but it's a the movie takes place in a
warehouse and there's a lot of talking
and it's like it's just going to be an
acting movie I kind of like your idea if
you were doing an action movie that you
are repitching with women but I don't
feel like you picked that you sort of
sold me on it but a movie that doesn't
actually do rather watch Amy Scher eat a
tampon yeah that'
be that sounds he laughed he laughed no
but Andy
you put legal you cast Rihanna as
legalist so I'm not taking you seriously
again well you should because here's the
thing you you criticize him for doing
the same thing you're just like yeah hey
let's just take a movie and replace
girls yeah that's really cool my movie
would Lord of the Rings porn parody
doesn't do
that offender Bo parody my movie would
actually be better wait I still don't
get why the Rock is in the all female
version no because you gender swap oh
Julia Roberts was in Oceans 11 I assume
they'll make her a dude right
bu not to help you but no well you did
and thank you um no my I'm the only one
pitching that this movie would be better
than the original if you cast all women
it would be uh they would get along more
they bore me wouldn't uh try to steal
the ring women get along better than men
and they work together and they would
for directions true Ro F Checker yes I
don't know I I all right you sexist
pieces of [__] I'm not going to make
that sweeping generalization
I I think women are great I think
they're wonderful women are more
levelheaded but also
women you need to be levelheaded to get
to Mordor this movie would cat fight on
the way to Mordor okay well go go watch
your original sexist version with Peter
isn't let me ask you this what are the
Orcs going to be huh what are the Orcs
going to be men's right
activists that's amazing this is
becoming something completely other than
the Lord yeah Ben Carson candidate the
question wasn't wasn't a an all female
remake it's an all female version so you
can do different would be better there
was girl jackass there were girl jack
there was rad girls on MTV and it was
unwatchable if you check that out it's
really really bad when they tried to
just assemble people who didn't grow up
together like the jackass guys who
weren't all friends already so cast
people who grew up together that's an
easy fix but you can't if we can't pick
Shazam then that's a c out yeah you're
doing the mondy silver and Amy Scher
they know each other and they'd be funny
if get them I'm just do stunts with each
other and yours is just like cosplay
yours is just cosplay it's not cosplay
why is yours better with that cosplay
it's not cosay you should have drink
beer on the show yours isn't cosplay no
it's a this is the most cosplay of all
it's a better movie and I've given
reasons why it' be more enjoyable you
have the guy that so mine has the guy
that doesn't necessarily write the most
realistic female characters but the
coolest ones and bring them Spencer let
me ask you uh so they you have the
iconic black suits from Reservoir Dogs
what are the women going to be wearing
in your version strong pants suits Su
you know just Blazers like come on or
they can just wear suits ridiculous why
are they not wearing suits they can uh
they want to dress up for i' never heard
for the record I'd never heard of these
things you told me so therefore they
don't think they were the right versions
if you did a proper big budget search
and Quest you would find the right crew
that would make it funny it would make
us all laugh and they this is my sham
argument and to me it is nice to to let
girl because they don't girls don't
really get to do that very often
bridesmaids was the thing I think
surprised everybody and let girls be the
guys and to me that's what I want to do
and why can't we see it do have to be so
gross final arguments Nick women are
great sure okay we all agree with that
that's a mic drop right there my wife
did a great job picking these she's
wonderful she did she's wonderful shout
to I mean I did I want to keep talking
but yes I think there's just something
more original and fun and actually
doable whereas I do think these are both
cosplay in away and I think Tarantino
writes great female characters she's
proven it I don't want to see them go
back to the why is it better why is it
better than the original who said it has
to be better than the original I think
can coexist yours will not be better
than the original Rihanna as legalist I
mean I think that's I can't take it
seriously wi Gollum is not taking it
seriously yes it is Spencer I don't it's
funny no I'm it's great these are never
going to uh surpass the original because
it's just a dumb idea is to just
blanketly replace the entire cast with
women just because but at least are you
calling Sandra Bullock stupid no I am
not she's a a beautiful intelligent
woman I'm sure but for my with jackass
is that the feeling of that was that
these guys were already doing jackass
stuff and they were plucked out of
obscurity and given a TV show you can't
assemble a jackass like they all had
this camaraderie of guys that had just
all been together forever Reservoir Dogs
quent Tarantino has a proven track
record of making great cool female
characters and there's room to do
another Heist gone wrong kind of
theatrical dialogue heavy imagine um
Thurman cutting off a guy's uh balls
strapped to a chair like you can do a
version of this movie with W that sounds
like my movie wait
holy crap you guys you brought it y'all
brought you know I mean I I love Rihanna
I mean she's hella fine so yeah I I I
wouldn't mind seeing her in a movie did
you see Battleship cuz no well no
boom I I just I I like I like her her
songs and her uh Instagram pictures uh
Spencer you I had a good argument but
you brought in pants suits a you're all
sexist bastards red Roy Nick you Des you
did describe uh something really
creative and you're you're a creative
young man I'd put you in a gifted in
talented program for creativity but you
described something that wasn't Lord of
the Rings the conflict what the ring
does to their minds is part of the joy
of that movie that Joy I wanted that I
don't want to see nine hours worth of
movie that could be done in an hour and
45 minutes Andy I I I really liked what
you were saying but I feel like Spencer
had the perfect takedown with the rad
girls thing from m TV we s we sort of
saw it and also um you said uh we can
find a group of women that grew up
together or could be Amy Schumer and
Sarah Silverman but they're different
kinds of comedians so at the end of the
day the one I'd be most interested in
seeing is the reservoir dogs remake I
think uh Tarantino is the guy that
writes the coolest uh parts for women
and that you you that was the most
interesting movie that was pitched
Spencer gets the Point Roxy might have
something to say Roxy
you're going to be excited to know that
there is currently a play in Los Angeles
called Reservoir [__] I didn't want
to say that out loud cuz I thought it'd
be sexist I'm glad someone else came up
with that oh that the title yeah at the
try stage so maybe you want to get some
tickets to that and also the internet
believes that men get along way better
than women it's it's pretty unanimous
across the internet internet yep because
apparently the internet is scared Every
Woman away so Women Believe women are
made to believe all their lives to
protect what's theirs that's the
consensus did that come from the
gamergate website yes it did um look
I'll be honest this doesn't look good
cuz those were my three good
answers then I stopped trying so well
thanks for remitting it I'm going to use
that gentlemen round four cens is
unbeatable anyway Spencer the win come
on it's already an speed every so do I
oh cool all right ooh I've been
preparing for Monday Night Raw um allow
me to bring the heat once again the crow
reboot is very much alive with director
Corin Hardy on board for to helm the
project friend of the show Miss movies
we love Miss movies at Miss movies asked
us who should play Eric Draven the crow
himself in the reboot and we are going
to start with who Eric Draven who's the
crow the crow himself Brandon
Lee Spencer we start with you uh a
similarly silly name Wen Phoenix is Eric
Draven the crow uh I picked waen cuz
he's crazy and he's frightening and you
kind of get the idea that he's not
hugely imposing but he might be able to
hold himself in a fight but the guy can
go dark uh he gets dark and weird in
Gladiator he gets dark and weird in the
master and his it's kind of a real life
mirrors the movies thing because he's so
intense and very clearly troubled like
when he pretended he was a rapper and
when he um uh on the red carpet when he
said there was a frog in his hair and he
was clearly on troms like this guy's not
all right um you know the the of of the
crow was offered to River Phoenix and he
turned it down so there's a nice bit of
synergy there and uh just like and waen
would turn it down just like
iten might but this is this is pie in
the sky and then uh his last name means
a bird that dies and Rises From the
Ashes just like the crow Phoenix very
poetic Nick Mundy talk to us okay well I
don't know who you picked but neither of
these guys would ever do this garbage
heap of a movie guys here's some science
the crow is a shitty movie it was bad
and uh this the sequels were [__] the
Remake will be bad they can't find a
director they can't do anything Corin
Hardy yeah who the hell is that this
movie will be bad so that's why I want
to put Jim car as the crow cuz if you
thought Ace Ventura and Liar Liar were
zany you haven't seen anything till a
godp powerered zombie pulls mad cat hij
Jinx against his and his wife's
murderers who where we find that emo
picture of Jim car what's that from
that's why Jim car to play Flor hey guys
I love Jim car and I love the mask and I
think it would be hilarious as a
superpowered dead guy and his Crow
sidekick voiced by Peter Dinklage kills
the people who killed him just imagine
an unhit Eric Draven or whatever the
hell his name is played by the gymster
himself as he hunts his beloved that
looks awful like that movie was awful so
that is just helping you lose no give me
a mask give me a fun years ago he's 10
years older pick up fun Jim Carrey
picture as a you know it'll be a laugh
right as he snuffs out his killers and
the people who killed his family uh um
hello Devil's Night knock knock it's Jim
Carrey as the crow here to kill the
devil like I'm gonna watch the hell out
of that movie oh wow okay uh Andy uh I'm
picking Jake Gyllenhaal who would you
know why well none of these people would
do it let's be honest Jim car's not
doing it either Jim Carrey hates
violence he did kickass 2 which actually
was kind of fun and then he completely
tanked the movie and renounced it so
there's no
chance in hell that Jim Carrey can do
this movie because he'll ruin it so
you're out again here's my problem I
agree Wen is really weird and dark you
kept saying and I agree and I love that
but Eric Draven needs to have both sides
before he goes to Revenge you need to
see him in love and have that really
touching moment and I think Jake
Gyllenhaal has both of those way better
Jake Gyllenhaal has done romantic
comedies he's been that that that even
in Brokeback to an extent and then
loveing other drugs like he's done he's
done it all he's a bigger range where
wen's only going to be crazy and I
wouldn't mind seeing Wen be crazy but
the Revenge story and the why I like the
crow I don't why you hate the crow is
because you see him and his wife get
murdered and you see that love and that
seriousness and then he goes and goes
crazy and so w i mean wen's great but
Jake Jal can also do that he did it in
Nightcrawler amazingly and he has that
range and I think he's got those crazy
eyes when he GES does it like it'd be
awesome to watch him see it it's not a
question of who would do it it's who we
want to see and I think if he did it and
they took the seriousness that they did
a Nightcrawler that movie would be
awesome cool mix it up snipe each other
I don't want to see another s bastard
mop and wine through alternative best of
1994's best of alternative music that
was that was a good soundtrack the
soundtrack was way better now we're
talking about soundtrack I'm into thep
solid but I just I don't want Nails I
don't want to see I don't want to see
the problem is we're getting bad remakes
off good movies I don't want a bad
remake off a bad movie that's what I
wanted there's so much comedy in the
crow crow like that's a no I want to
watch a funny The Crow because it could
be just like the crow 4 with Dennis
Hopper the devil it was hilarious it was
really funny Jim Carrey as the crow
would be hilarious cuz he's zany and fun
and can do all sorts of he's not zany
and fun anymore that's the problem Che
out I almost picked seriously because
Jim Carrey could go super dark it would
be kind of an interesting turn for him
now that he takes himself so seriously
it kind of fits look I have a title for
this movie The Mask 2 The Crow I like it
uh I guess my problem with uh with Jake
gylenhaal and your argument is I don't
think we need both Ides the the oh you
need to believe them in love the
flashback scenes are like there's one
scene or two maybe where he's like
proposing to his girlfriend then she's
horribly raped and murdered like that's
all you need for the bright side of the
crow the rest of the time is the moping
around and Jake Gyllenhaal he's a great
actor I know he would commit to it and I
know Nightcrawler was like a turn for
the dark creepy side but he's still too
like boyish he's kind of like
congratulations he didn't blink in
Nightcrawler but you're still like you
don't scare me Jake jonald is not
scarying Phoenix scares me Jake J is
scary Southpaw is scary he's he's proven
himself scary yeah yeah like he can go
and he does commits and so to me I think
it's unfair to say that I also think the
problem with the crow is I wanted a
little bit more of the emotional before
you just get a rape scene like I think
you need to see you need to see a little
bit more because the revenge and the
Darkness is going to be even that much
worse if you see them are they tell me
again why gyllen Hall would be a better
choice than Phoenix I just think like I
said you need both sides he's saying
that part's not important I think you
need to see the the fun side for that
depressing dark side to hit even harder
and I think they do it a little bit in
the movie right but in this remake I
think you'd want to do a little bit more
and Jake Jal could give you that whereas
Watkins not Watkin going to show up and
be a crazy person and I like crazy
person but I want Crow's a crazy person
Jake Jon can also be a crazy person for
the record I think really well and I
think you need the what's nice about it
separates the two is mine can give you a
little bit more of the emotional better
than he will you do need both sides but
the more important side is the crow side
not the of Eric Draven happy and love
side the important part is that he can
pull off the crow which is a scary
psychopath that m The Immortal murder
zombie that's the guy from her will pull
that off yeah you guys are well you guys
are just pitching the same movie you
guys are just pitching the same movie
The it's a remake so let's do something
different let's do something fun turn it
into a direct to DVD mask sequel yeah
because I'm tired of the direct TVD Crow
sequels Nick take Nick take a moment and
Jim car is great with catchphrases like
smoking and all righty then what's his
catchphrase for the crow going to be
knock knock who's there the crow mother
effer cuz I can't say
it it could have been better no I know
well was let me think about it okay uh
by the way by way final arguments all
nighty then that's good that's better
all nighty then oh that's pretty good
Spencer final arguments go for it I I
think I said all I have to say Jake
jillen Hall uh could probably nail the
the positive puppy side but the more
important is the dark threatening crazy
side which Wen Phoenix is perfectly
suited for and the Brandon Lee walk uh
River Phoenix like dead sibling
connection is very strange and
interesting to me that part of the
reason why the crow was so popular is
because the onset tragedy this continues
the Mythos W Phoenix is a better actor
than any of them Nick I don't want
another sad Bastard movie I want
something where is different and unique
and fun and The Mask that's why I want
Jim Carrey and the crow I think Jake
will embed himself in it more than
you're giving him credit and I think W
will get too headyy with it and he'll
grow a beard and he'll try and do it in
a weird artistic way cuz you can't
control him and while I get the idea of
him doing it in the cool we want him to
I don't think he will I think he'll go
in some weird artistic Direction like he
always does and I don't think this is
the movie for that I want to see him do
that in in Spike Jones movies and not in
this Jake jillell just recently with
Southpaw and um Nightcrawler he's like
at that verge of a perfect way to just
go complete bat [__] crazy which I want
to see him
do time wow dog G it no one talks [__]
about Jim carrying this yes I did right
away I said yours isn't serious because
it is that's what I want to watch he
hates the violence he's not going to do
a violent movie you know Nick I've
always thought wouldn't it be cool if
they took like a superhero movie and
just like cast like Steve Bushi as the
superhero or something or something
weird like super with rain Wilson yeah a
little bit a little bit um he'd be a
better Doctor Strange than uh patch yeah
but I don't know I feel like you we we
took it too much and just made it this
other thing which it needs to be because
the original thing sucks yeah and it's
like when are we remaking Johnny neonic
Oo we get keu back that's not the same
it's the same thing no it's not they
don't have Johnny neonic shirts at Hot
Topic it's Nick again you you get points
for most entertaining okay you you uh
you're a Whimsical gentleman and I love
you for it but for for the legit
argument it comes down to Phoenix and uh
gyllen hall for me and I I feel like one
of your arguments undermined you a
little bit Spencer in as much as I don't
know if we want to be reminded of that
tragedy you know and also this movie's
got to need all the Press
Andy Andy hit me where I live because I
thought uh Nightcrawler was my favorite
film of 2014 and I thought Jake
Gyllenhaal was robbed not giving not
being given uh an Oscar nomination and I
would love to see him I I think he could
really pull it off and Andy won me over
with that Andy gets the point for Jake
Gyllenhaal and Roxy facts were good the
number one alternative album in 1994 was
Green Day Dookie so thought you'd like
to know that oh yeah thank where was The
Crow on that
it had to be up there was popular right
welcome
to it wasn't dooky but yeah
no what is round five round
five a theme park in Dubai will feature
a Hunger Games ride oh man how about
that Robert Nickerson Robert
33772 tweeted in Pitch the ultimate
Hunger Games ride for the upcoming theme
park okay uh I'm very excited Andy uh uh
sorry Nick we'll start with you yeah um
the one thing everyone loves in this
world is uh the old rock and jock
softball and basketball um you know yeah
no everyone loves that remember those
you agree Spencer they had their moments
I was that yes was more like okay I
heard
you uh I'm a huge fan um look I wanted I
I think the fans should compete in
hunger games like like you know fighting
the Jack bees or whatever they're called
and uh fighting off the title tracker
jackers or I've never really watched
Hunger Games um you know but do that but
then also while you're doing it your
like teammate from your district is a
personality from early 90s MTV like Dan
Cortez or Kennedy or Eric nce or Puck so
you're competing in these hunger game
matches with Rock and jock and that's
why this would be the mtvs Rock and
hunger and jock and games and this would
be the most fun I could ever have in my
life I mean they're in Dubai it's the
playground of the rich they can summon
the MTV people Andy I'm so I still need
to understand what he's doing I don't
fully follow pretend like I did you're
going to fight luck judging that one
you're GNA fight tracker jackers with
Dan
Cortez said it better than I could have
ever uh I'm going for a version of the
American Idol experience guys I don't
know if you know this so I think it
closed down because American Idol is not
as popular but we need to refill it with
something else um I basically they
brought up singers from the audience to
compete against the show and I want to
do that here I want to bring audience
members to be selected to be tribute for
the crowd to watch as they partake in
American gladiatores SL wipe outes
challenges that are similar like the
Indian John St Indian John stunt show
mixed with the idol experience where
they're all safe safe experiences
they'll fight other Gladiators and
they'll be in padded suits and we get to
watch as they fall and do crazy stuff
the best part of American Gladiator is
always like those those the one where
they had the Nerf guns and they had to
shoot the Tower and the guys in there
and then they had to not get hit by the
tennis balls like that was fun I really
want to see that and I think it'd be fun
to play people would line up to do it
and then we the audience can give uh
prizes to the PE the tributes that we
want to win so as they're competing you
just got an extra couple balls because
the audience voted you so I think very
fun to play and I want to go be in The
Hunger Games have you ever done anything
like this personally oh I've never done
wipe out how what are you implying yeah
you can't Google around and find I get
tweets yes I was on Couple's wipe out
and I get tweets were you on Wipeout
that's a whole another story for a whole
another time awesome talk to us so mine
starts out it's kind of a Disney jungle
cruise beginning where you're on a
propaganda fuel train tour through the
capital uh through all the different
districts of penm you do a lot of fan
service you get to see what's going on
in each district but the ride is
hijacked by Katniss and the Rebellion
Jennifer Lawrence you know hacks into
the Train's TV cameras tells you you
know the Revolution begins now the train
is derailed a controlled derailing and
it gets boarded by District 13 and an
actress playing Katniss everyone gets a
bow and arrows quiver of soft arrows and
you get to shoot a bunch bunch of out of
work actor goons as they as they Rush
your position and so you the MTV guys
yeah exactly Jesse Camp is one of them
so you you get to fire arrows at them
and that uh you beat back the capitals
forces and you exit through the gift
shop okay uh so it's like Star Tours
meets uh bow and arrow laser tag meets
laser tag star tour meets oh that's
interesting uh have at it guys well Andy
sounds fun to do but not fun to watch
like it'd be cool to be one of the kids
and you know the kids are going to want
to get in line and go 177 times until
they get picked but you're going to have
to explain to your crying child why they
can't ride the ride that it has to be
audience selection right well that
happens in Indiana Jones they pull
people to be on the the any of the stunt
shows they do the the at Universal and
whatnot they'll pee people from the
crowd if you go to pen and Teller that
PE pick people from the crowd that makes
you come back and it makes you want to
wait in line and do it whereas yours
that's logistically impossible to give
them bows and arrows digital or whatever
maybe but you told me they're not
they're Nerf guns and that's never gonna
happen mine's logistically tough I get
it as well but you can weed them out you
can have people apply to be in the show
early there's ways to make that work
whereas I just feel like yours isn't and
yours is boring they do that currently
on the tram tour and and fast the fast
ride the King Kong experience they're
all let Downs they're not that exciting
a mediocre ride than to than to watch
someone else have fun that's true people
drive the Water World stunt show was I
love the water exactly and was there
forever and people and watched it no
one's in the water who cares you're
watching actors why wouldn't you want to
watch someone
I have a question for you okay if you
have Puck from 9s Real World um in this
in your dist can you trust him can you
trust him as you're
competing how are you going to keep Puck
sober to arrive at the theme park where
he has to do his believe alcohol is
legal in Dubai um totally yeah no I
think it's amazing to have these Hunger
Games obstacle courses and then you
compete with you know your fellow
tribute who happens to be 1990s MTV
personality instead of having some
nobody or some stunt actor like you know
at Disney World you have Kennedy or you
have beas Kennedy is a host on Fox News
yeah well or or the entire real world's
one Road Rules cast I think it's just
you can do the Title Wave you can
compete you're also learning about
teamwork and should you trust this
person you can paint hand like wood
hands you could have you could ride
chariots and then spin in fire why is
that what do you think of that IDE I
just
noise I mean come on you know it is and
he has already admitted he phoned this
one in no I didn't so I I yours is the
one I'm I'm lasering in on I just feel
like I don't want to watch that that
sounds boring who would want to watch it
I don't care about watching I care about
doing it I want to do it I I care about
doing mine more and I think to go
against what you said if people don't
want to watch they do they watch
American Ninja Warrior they watch
Wipeout they watch them Idol experience
where people were plucked and sung in
front of them and that's even boringer
to me said it watch get get argued said
it down the americ ID the show's boring
games is in Idol is not that's why how
are people not going to get injured and
eyes going to get taken out with your
idea of shooting arrows they're foam
they're fo tip arrow to the eye well the
you know the capitals goons all have
mass um they're like Stormtroopers but I
mean you're going to have to explain to
your crying child why the kid next to
him got picked and is having fun explain
a lot of things to crying children at
Disney world is just one on the list you
don't want to make it easy on him and
then you're saying oh but these shows
are awesome I don't think it's going to
be that awesome to watch out of shape
Bay and run through an American
Gladiator that the Water World ride
thing was fun to watch because those
were actors those were St final thoughts
final stunt I will give the final
thought just so I can react though there
will be stuntmen in mind they're
fighting against stuntmen just because
you're putting one in doesn't mean
they're the star of the show they're
part of it they get an experience and
then other people will be in it too so
to me if you watched and liked Water
World imagine if one some person could
have got to ride on the jet ski with the
Mariner during that show that would have
made it actually even better cuz then
you would have come back back to se it
again maybe I'll get picked to be on the
jet ski that's what I'm pitching got it
fair enough but the the way I understood
it was that everyone in the show is
picked out of the audience no you're
fighting the capital which would be
goons and stunt people and other people
involved in the show but the only the
only other point that I'll make about
mine is that mine's the only one that
isn't Pro Hunger Games you know the
moral of this whole franchise that the
Hunger Games are bad Katniss is leading
the Rebellion against the capital you're
cheering for blood and circuses mine
also mine actually fits with the theme
of the movie which is Hunger Games are a
thing you're trapped that you want to
escape from not something you want to
send your children into look if you're
doing a theme park in Dubai it might as
well be the capital so for their point
of view the capital are the good guys in
Dubai well one question you said you
mentioned beas is Mike Judge going to be
in Dubai for this no it' probably be a
mascot costume okay U no what I want is
a fully interactive obstacle course
based on the Hun g games and what's
better than doing with by yourselfgo
yeah what are you running through fogs
and what what obstacles like bees going
at you like Nick anything else to add uh
just give me the point okay wow I just
want my point you guys should I mean if
Universal Studios is listening give
these men contracts to design rides Roxy
uh anything uh to sway us either way uh
Puck is available to work right now
after after getting out of prison in
2009 he is looking for jobs that don't
include working with ugly stinky chicks
God which they do not have in Dubai
thank you so he's available okay good
good to know good to know thank you for
looking up his Craigslist ad JT throw my
point um Nick you're you you you what
what would what would you rather doew
you rather do you view the world through
joyful glasses what would you rather do
you're a beautiful man and and I and I
love you yep you're all it comes down to
Andy and Spencer once again you're all
just stuck up nerds and I Spencer
Spencer had the had had the had the
argument that it's in the spirit of of
The Hunger Games mine mine win the
hunger wait whoa whoa the tributes win
my game how Spencer had the argument
that's in the spirit of The Hunger Games
but the more fun ride the more fun
experience I don't want to sit on a
train and that arrows there arrows going
to be going everywhere that that is
chaos let face a game failed American
Idol thing that that is chaos uh you you
had me when you said like an American
Gladiator St style obstacle course that
sounds like the most fun incarnation of
The Hunger Games I want to compete in
The Hunger Games I want to watch a thing
about The Hunger Games I want to do
Andy's Andy gets the point mine was the
same as losing but that was unfair
that's not what am I ride mine was
Andy's plus
Puck Puck's Puck is GNA be sticking his
fingers in people's peanut butter okay
no that's Pedro round
six
no gentlemen this week's Honest Trailers
is a special one as the screen junkies
team turns their gaze to Terminator
Genesis it's an honest trailer you don't
want to miss coming on Tuesday everybody
so it's time to decide what is the worst
action sequel of all time and we're
going to start with Mr Andy signore this
one was tough and I know what you guys
picked and this I think will be actually
a tough fight I think but I got to go
with Matrix Revolutions Matrix 3 to me
took something that the Matrix to find a
whole new genre that I thought they
could have exploited completely done so
many fun things with they made part two
which is not a good movie but it's still
not three part two had moments of action
and things that I feel like at least
showed a world that could be that could
work Matrix Revolutions went they went
just full on craziness and there's just
nothing in it worthy it is completely
Fall Down The Rabbit Hole uh it just
turns into nonsensical Madness the the
action is boring it you can't follow it
they took the namesake of the Matrix and
turned it off pretty much and then went
to Zion and then spent all this money
and all these Resources with such a cool
idea and just completely blundered it
like to such a degree that I will have
plenty more to say but uh your two which
I know I don't think were as
disappointing as mine gotcha Spencer
talk to us uh my pick is Terminator
Genesis it's the worst
movie forget action sequel It's one of
the worst movie goinging experiences
I've ever had I almost walked out I
should have walked out I was there next
to him I didn't miss anything by not
walking out uh you know the Matrix well
I I'll get before I counter your guys's
um this movie wasn't is bad on its own
it went back in time to ruin the only
Terminator movies you actually loved
this went back in time to ruin
Terminator one and ruined Terminator 2
Matrix Revolutions you can sleep soundly
knowing that the Matrix still exists and
happened now Terminator 1 and two are no
longer Canon because this movie exists
and I'll have more to say later you guys
are both cowards because I did walk out
of my movie I could only last 45 minutes
of Die Hard 5 which you said termin
Genesis is one of the worst movies in
the world this is the worst movie ever
made this is worse than the room it's
just pure pure hot garbage and we should
not dignify it with any more words
here's the one thing it's funny you both
have J Courtney in your movies yeah yeah
no it's not that funny it's not funny at
all here's the thing that Matrix
Revolution did common denominator at
least what Matrix Revolution did was it
killed off its hero so it probably
guarantees that they'll never make it
Neo's Jesus he's coming back but you
know who's alive John mlan probably to
make
godamn
movie and and you at least had the honor
to kill off to Snuff your own film which
is at least honorable didn't only snuff
out its own film uh well it threatens
you with more uh sequels because it ends
on a cliffhanger and like I said it goes
back in time mine is also a PG-13
downgrade from an R-rated franchise mine
also has ja Courtney in it was it in
Focus was your movie in focused parts of
it it mine was not and it was shot on a
GoPro and then like Andy's this mine was
also a confusing jumbled mess with bad
CGI that was preceded by some other bad
movies and you know by the time reloaded
came around you knew the Matrix wasn't
going to be great again you knew it had
the car chase in it but you knew it was
bad it ended with to be continued you
knew it was going to be more of the same
by then here here's also the other
problem with I have with the Matrix the
M the first Matrix is pretty good it's
pretty damn good I love like pretty good
it's great but it's no Die Hard or
Terminator sure no it's not so like the
level of here's a
matrix three and four that your movie
has but I'm just talking about the best
four steps to get to where yours was
which I think disqualifies it a bit and
here's something I'm going to say that I
think you're not going to agree with but
I don't care take John mlan out of that
movie and it's a fine generic action
movie not a terrible let's watch a j
Courtney vehicle but you're wrong some
fun Parts it's quick it's not that
painful it's why is your the reason di
five is terrible is because John mcan's
in it but John mlan has become a parody
and it I don't take it seriously I also
don't take your ser seriously you're
saying they've gone back and destroyed
the movies no they haven't no one takes
they murder the T800 they his heart out
in the first 20 minutes what did they do
in part three what did they do in part
four who cares no one takes those
seriously we're going to still only take
one two no cares about the Matrix your F
I'm trying to tell them why theirs is
because your yours don't matter yours
are just nonsense mine destroyed an
amazing franchise that should have had
sequels now here wa everyone's saying oh
two was the thing I disagree I think two
has flaws I think two is a mess he meets
the architect and things go around
here's where mine could have gone here's
where mine could have gone what if the
Matrix was part of the Matrix what if it
reloaded and the architect revealed that
were in The Matrix and we suddenly
realized they got to get out of another
thing what if they could given us
another mind thing which they could have
done in three and they were teasing and
they were building this philosophical
crazy thing which I think had they
delivered on would have been amazing and
instead it completely proved that they
didn't know what they're doing
completely ruined it and the Matrix is
Iconic in a way that I think should have
had good I like the use of iconic wa
okay here's a question I have to ask
both of you what would you rather see
less a Terminator sequel a matrix sequel
or a die Terminator sequ die yours is
shorter and yours has the good stuff
with Arnold I say old Arnold was fun to
watch the scene where he gets the
picture and goes back you've admitted
that you like those parts are good you
know what you know what I don't need to
hear anymore you guys are all talking
about crap the the crap bucket the the
garbage bag of movies but the thing that
won me over Nick's the only one actually
walked out of his movie okay um to me
that's the mic drop here Andy you um
it's a bad movie but you didn't tell me
why yours was specifically the worst
movie and feel like I didn't get a
chance get a chance to do that H got to
cut us off I told you you go quicker but
don't cut off our our arguments cuz I
have tons I can tell you why if that's
your reasoning for ending me you read
the you read the credits but he can have
it but whatever I didn't I I was just
getting started but that's cool you know
just up man you're the judge uh judge is
the judge you know what I got I got on
the board every every once in a while
there there's there's a movie fight
that's a first round knockout Nick Mundy
you get the point is not the worst I
would have walked out I had a ride could
have just walked out I also don't
believe you walked out he's just saying
that I I don't believe you didn't see
the whole I don't I don't
believe I never saw The Matrix
Revolutions I'm not going to waste my
time Nick deserves a point let's you you
can have it Nick Nick deserves also want
your pity Point want your pity point I
want a point for Jim Carrey cuz that's a
movie that people would actually watch
the round then don't let him keep
talking yeah
okay 2our episode Roxy any thoughts it
was it was all good I forgot to tell you
guys before that the crow was number 37
on the albums list but in terms
criminally underrated you guys did a
good job thatp song is amazing we worst
of the worst so after six rounds it's
Nick one point Spencer two points and
three points so it's going to be Andy
and Spencer in the I like Nick you you
made it it's fair I didn't walk out I
didn't walk out of a move I've never
walked out of a single movie oh I have
ladybugs and that is a it is a fair
point when you walk out it's pretty bad
look look I don't think we need to
subjugate ourselves to [__] we
should have a higher standard I will say
again sorry let's keep moving it's not
that bad if you take John McLean out of
it you're not even a Die Hard movie it
just has the name on
it fellas it's time for the speed
round now this is a chance for five more
points to win the game the panelist with
the lowest points is automatically out
that is Nick and I will ask the question
we're looking for fast quick answers
with short follow-ups on an either or
question if two players choose the same
answer the player who said it first gets
to argue for that answer the other
player has to argue for a different
answer this week the player who answers
first gets 15 seconds to answer the
second player gets 15 seconds to argue
their choice then both players get get a
5sec rebuttal to make so basically it's
the same as every week okay this week
can you respect the no no I just making
cuz he was confusing me first time
hosting first time everyone knows it's
the same as always you're killing it
great thank you no you are but I just
make sure it wasn't I appreciate I'm
having a lot of fun thank you for having
me uh Roxy are you ready with the timer
I got you okay so you're going to hit
that time speed Round music is playing
all
right our first speed round uh question
first I'm G to ask Spencer are you ready
oh I'm ready Andy we we are both
terrible at this this will be
interesting all right Bumble our way to
the finish I'm going for
Spencer based on the arguments Nick my
arm hair is standing up not the best
kisser okay these two movies are in the
Bargain
Bin which one do you
buy Speed 2 cruise control or Tri XX
State of the Union speed two cruise
control okay trip X State of the Union
and he has triple X Spencer you have
Speed 2 cruise control go for it true
Speed 2 cruise control uh doesn't have
Keanu in it but it has an amazing
underrated performance by William defo
as the villain he's cool he's creepy
he's just as good as the guy from the
bad guy who I'm forgetting now from the
first one Dennis Hopper Dennis Hopper
thank you but the uh okay time your say
Jason Patrick mine has Ice Cube mine has
Samuel Jackson mine like really actually
it doesn't matter that the first one's
bad yours is so bad that it completely
ruins the entire funest of speed you're
like oh they made Speed 2 and it's on a
cruise ship it's so boring trip XX is
just fun action you can watch mindlessly
and get away with which is not offensive
offensive 5sec rebuttal speed or triple
X2 took the franchise from Vin Diesel
that could have been Vin Diesel's
lifelong it's true and he's coming back
to do another one so thank you for
reminding me so clearly didn't kill it
yours
did okay uh that Willam defo was a great
Point very watchable but uh he Andy made
the point that it's just a fun action
movie and I'm an ice cube fan I'm an NWA
fan and it also didn't kill the
franchise Andy overwhelmed you with
final point and gets the point
damn next next
up Hollywood's best
Jeff Jeff Daniels Jeff Bridges okay we
have Jeff Daniels we have Jeff Bridges
ooo formidable both strong
actors Spencer talk to me well I always
get these guys confused but I will pick
Jeff Daniels because he's in my favorite
comedy of all time Dumb and Dumber and
he's got the dramatic chops I'm pretty
damn sure he's got an Oscar he can uh
carry a does he uh he can carry a TV
show he can carry a movie he's more
flexible than Jeff Bridges Jeff Bridges
is the dude Jeff Bridges is starm man
Jeff Bridges is so much better uh than
Jeff Daniels uh he's won an Oscar for a
crazy heart uh je he's just got the
range he can play guitar he can make
anything the just the big labasi alone
Jeff doesn't have a role like that and
makes 5sec rebuttal I I can't tell these
two apart I always I always mix the two
up I thought I picked
him but damn it I picked the wrong Jeff
you picked Dumb and Dumber Dumb and
Dumber Andy yes he picked Dumb and
Dumber I know who I picked and my guy's
better because he can't even know who's
either of them are okay does uh does
Jeff Daniels have an Oscar I don't think
he does he doesn't no he doesn't got got
yeah um new
[__] uh you Ned yourself you should
have kept going you should have kept
going because you said Dumb and Dumber
but then you thought it was the other
guy uh like it's just worlds folding
upon in themselves uh Andy gets that
point yeah em yes Oscar now there it is
okay there you go and Andy had a a lot
of good uh points about the body of work
so if I'm right he needs to get the next
three to tie yes do it Andy is up 5 to
two let's do Spencer needs to run the
table i' I've lost like this so don't
worry best movie with the word Road in
it
you
idiots best movie with the word Road
road to Road Warrior Road House you dumb
bastards Road predition Road Warrior
Andy you're up first uh Road Warriors I
even the best one uh road to predition
is beautiful the score the shooting Sam
man directing Tom Hanks uh Jude Law
there's so much fun at from a graphic
novel very rare to pull that off and
Road prod really it holds up it's really
well shot well done and it's just a
dramatic turn for everybody okay Spencer
Road Warrior set the stage for
post-apocalyptic awesome Wasteland
movies which is one of my favorite
genres without that you don't have the
better Mad Max Fury Road that we got
down the line Mel Gibson it launched him
and launched him into the American
Consciousness I just think yours is more
boring than you're admitting and I think
uh it's it it's gotten better now but
it's Ro PR and stronger uh it's not
boring if you look at it in terms of
what it gave us and what it set the
stage for later
wow you are allowed to use them to help
you just to remind you yeah Roadhouse
they ripped throats out yeah I would
like I would like to I I would like to
go uh to our uh our friends
Nick
um I didn't he didn't talk about why rot
a predition the flaws of it but he did
talk about the genre of thing so I'm
going to go with Spence okay
rocks um it's a tough call and it's hard
enough to keep time but uh
isn't it I I think that because of what
Nick just said that he didn't talk about
the flaws and and Andy talked about the
flaws and countered with him I would
actually go with Andy wow one one right
there you know what I I Spencer's point
about the post-apocalyptic world and uh
opening up that genre uh that was
although Andy had more that was the
overwhelming more powerful point and and
uh made it the more influential better
film I'm going with Road
Warrior
okay who
is the best actor or actress who is a
sir or a d
m we have Sir Anthony Hopkins first and
Sir Ian McKellen who goes first um I
Heard Sir Anthony Hopkins first Anthony
Hopkins multiple uh Oscar winter
Hannibal Lecter I think trumps all of
them there's he's made the villain if
you ever say best villain he's the
villain his work goes from Marvel movies
to dramatic Shakespeare movies such a
wide girth uh and such amazing
characters that he's he's built over the
years that Anthony Hopkins I think
Trump's GN off okay Ser melen is the he
is a he's the king of the genre actors
because he's got Magneto and he's got
Gandalf these are the big he's the
biggest icon in nerd culture yes
everyone points to Hannibal but that's
the only iconic role he
has 5 Seconds uh he's got so many more
Ro roles that I'm not thinking of right
now uh but
uh well exactly yeah uh two gigantic
franchises is better than one I'll take
Mel the same just Bree it out bre it out
okay time time C uh Roxy a two hour
episode we got I think you have to give
it to Spencer because I don't think that
Andy could come up in the clutch there
and think of other rules oh yeah Spencer
I bubbled that one it goes to Spencer 5
54 wow wow wow wow wow okay that's a big
moment
tell me the best movie starring Seth
Rogan knocked
up Tick
Tock 5050
5050 okay Knocked Up and 50/50 we heard
Knocked Up first go Spencer uh Knocked
Up Is AO and Rogan at the height of
their powers before it became cliche
before we realized this was a formula
this is the one that burst onto the
scene and said oh my God these guys are
funny they're relatable that's what
created the Seth Rogan archetype of the
kind of guy that won't grow up and acts
like Seth Rogan forc to accept
responsibility you said it yourself it's
cliche we liked at the time 50/50 was
where he could take the cliche and make
it dramatic and that film is very
underrated it's a serious movie about
his friend with cancer and they make it
funny so he's still able to keep what he
does but he in a newer more nuanced way
that to me is the best performance I
said it was cliche but it's it wasn't
cliche but it's become that now uh
what's more cliche than a guy going
through cancer bald jokes with Paul Ry
does it in every freaking movie and it
was funny but it's not the best when you
pile them together okay wow uh Nick what
do you
think
Spencer you're not going to give any
reasons why yeah why I don't they they
both weren't great they both weren't
great like like you know cuz he he
didn't do a Seth Rogan one like that
wasn't really Seth Rogan's movie and oh
semantics all right yeah no very much
Roxy I think if you had asked what was
the way that started the formula or the
first then I would give it to Spencer
but for the better movie I think Andy
made a better
argument
wow if either of you said this is the
end I would have gone with that that's
what I was thinking that's a good one
but it's an ensemble himself yeah yeah
um he's always playing himself
range best movie starring Seth that's
what got him into jobs am I still
allowed to argue to help you that's what
got Jord Le's
movie you're just there's a lot of
people in your movie think out loud let
me in I want to know best movie starring
Seth Rogan huh not best Seth Rogan movie
not
first uh for me Spencer made the point
that uh it it what it has become cliche
but knocked up is like kind of opened up
that genre so I I got to go with knocked
up cuz and when you think about it like
would you rather watch knocked up again
or 50/50 I respect your decision best
movie how is what it is not most iconic
movie but hey let's
continue we're all tied up ladies and
gentlemen here's your
tiebreaker Naked Gun or Hot Shots Hot
Shots
Jes we have Naked Gun versus Hot Shots I
heard Naked Gun first Naked Gun Leslie
neelson I think you wouldn't have hot
shots without it files and police squad
uh OJ Simpson could be good in it who
would have thought Naked Gun has so many
more jokes that's stronger Hot Shots is
funny Hot Shots part two is better Naked
Gun the original Weird Al Cameo the
zuckers I mean it's just it's it's the
one of the best uh I agree you wouldn't
have hot shots without Naked Gun you
wouldn't have Naked Gun without airplane
so this is in the genre of spoof movies
and uh OJ Simpson is now creepy when you
rewatch it uh Charlie Sheen is still
hilarious and part two is better than 33
and a third that's a lie when you did
best athlete in your space gy does it
hold up you said he was the best actor
OJ Simpson was spoiler hasn't even been
released to do with it anything else
they're both uh the the same movie
basically but this is more rewatchable
because it actually is more recent holds
up time time time time Andy gets it
naked Naked Gun is over Hot Shots all
day see I don't agree with I don't agree
with that but God you messed that one up
hot shot has one joke every 1.3 seconds
I counted yeah I don't a good argument
yes Hot Shot Hot Shots is better but oh
man Andy made the better argument in the
bubble Andy is our Victor oh my God my
first official solo win congratulations
Andy signor Spencer man you are brutal
Spencer you brought the pain Nick you
made me laugh all day long and I thank
you for it wow we're out of time sorry
if I went long my first time judging but
uh what what do you think of the show if
you're watching on YouTube please uh
tell us in the comments what you thought
more importantly tell us you did awesome
H for the record I loved it I was only
getting grumpy because I'm like how long
is this episode I I appreciate that and
I had I had a you were awesome you
really took this seriously I loved it
you were welcome back thank you I appr
their decisions but good job as AUD you
means I'm not welcome back to
host you your own show now um oh this
was awesome uh thank you Andy again for
letting us in on that awesome
announcement and everybody who's going
to be a part of that everybody yes
screen.com tell us what you want to see
us fight about uh subscribe to the RSS
feed on iTunes uh we have a new t-shirt
store District Lines tons of screen
junkies designs but most important is
the app and the website on November 17th
follow us on Twitter follow all of us on
Twitter can you give out our Twitter so
they know how to get all the info hell
yeah Spencer jgilbert Spencer jgilbert
let's watch some all movies together
dick Fundy yep let's get we on Mondays
guys oh it's so good guys get ready
booah Andy signor tweet me I'm going to
answer as many questions as I can for a
little bit on the couch our new host of
TV fights your your Twitter handle is
Roxy ster can't wait booah and uh I'm at
Hal Rudnick you guys thanks for watching
can you believe when we launch this
where where we've LED how how great is
this this so crazy air high five thank
you fans this is amazing thank you
everybody we'd be nowhere without you
thanks for watching
byebye every podcast we put on YouTube
comes with this Kick-Ass graphic listing
all the topics your screen junkies
podcasters are talking about if you
click the topics you can skip around and
choose your own podcast Battle Royale go
ahead try them all if you haven't
already subscribe to screen junkies on
YouTube to join us for future fights or
if you prefer to listen on iTunes click
the logo to download an audio
[Music]
version